le groupe de pirates russes No Name 057
poursuit sa tournée au Canada c'est
ainsi sur le réseau social telegram
qu'il revendique c'est plus récentes
cyberattaque dont celle qui paralyse le
site web et l'application Diderot Québec
qu'on a détecté cette nuit vers 3h du
matin des attaques de type déni de
service alors on parle de robot qui vont
simuler un nombre important de connexion
de tentatives d'accès au site en
simultané et ça a pour effet d'inonder
un site web résultat le site est
inaccessible plusieurs autres
organisations comme le port de Montréal
moi je vois le croire quand quand on va
avoir fait l'analyse complète de toute
la journalisation de tous ces serveurs
là moi je dis depuis longtemps je trouve
que la cibac humanité au Canada c'est
pas très au sérieux devant une menace
qui est bien réelle François Philippe
champagne appelle à la vigilance il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises chez nous qui ont
de la propriété intellectuelle qui ont
des secrets industriels il faut
s'assurer de bien les garder leur
vigilance surtout que d'autres attaques
pourraient se poursuivre dans les
prochains jours ici jacauderie
Charbonneau Radio-Canada Montréal